na vontade diz tudo dei a tempo e aí
galera que assistiu ao canal tudo com
vocês esse canal é meu é foi o que fiz é
o nome o índice fica aqui o meu nome
está aqui né gente aqui sou eu mesma
série tanto tempo eu faço vídeo acho que
o pessoal não deve conhecer mas quem é
esse você faça tanto e tanto tempo
instantâneo ficar porque tem teto pode
gravar pegar um segundo ela ficam por
fazer um vídeo quente e 80 eu tava no
carnaval carioca foi o carnaval eu
acordei agora eu fui curtir o carnaval é
o culto carvalho que tem em si não faz
me permitem que o dial carnaval não você
não pode baixar carnaval porque você não
é da oea se carnaval cada um fugiu de
janeiro ao carnaval o cara vai massa em
carnaval com carioca meu deus do céu
carioca tem aquela malandragem é aquela
coisa de maluco
ai nem tão gostoso assim nem eu quero me
segurar porque eu sou a pessoa que eu
não sei de bielsa pessoa cabeça me
aparece um lindo uma coisa eu tô mudar
muito bom cara bom demais é o que é isso
que também olha isso aí é o esqui whisky
tipo e tem álcool é o ic tem algum dia
já começa a oprah agora que saiu de
camarote eu já vendi ela estimando
pirata já começa a qantas com a toda vez
vou de carro a água de coco e uma dodge
no grupo da família você só fala merda
merda aí média vão dizer que é piada que
eu vou mandar a toalha já tem perto de
algum band e grupos família para
explodir no ritmo de tango gente
completa só dá nas parente porque se
tornam togo e só percebeu só foi um golo
e é por isso que a fpb lugar público não
sei como vai ser a merda é vedada a
transferência foi o de boicotar assim
não não tanto pelo mesmo placar e matar
márcia tal vale pouco vai começar a
passar vai ficar animado por não sair
veio num top
aqui há gato vai negar a tequila 115
alegação a limpo o salário mesmo agora é
só uma lista bacana bacana eu estou só
passa massa foi mais algum bom toque de
bola e só chegou em abuja
não vou tomar um pouco ali onde o iphone
mas não foi a tequila e disse bom demais
hammond mais pode crer que a brigada
militar o sangue é é não entender
veja meu filho do rei
veja meu liga acabar aí eu achava vinha
aí eu acho que o max carnaval que ele
sempre transforma qualquer ritmo mesmo
aqui ó tá tá tá tá tá tá
achei pegar pra mim cola primeiro beijo
pra você ficar em ritmo de carnaval tem
que botar olha antes de cada frase olha
tem gente que tem cheiro de cola de
avelã
olha olha assim a rocha pra você que
estava que sofre
olha a briga levou a facada casa pega
metralhar o tatá assim adorava voltar à
briga
a banda agora vai ficar bem baixinho foi
baixando na briga o irmão levou a facada
aqui ó
a médica estava lançando aqui mais mas
já fui atender o cara pegou colocou
dentro da van
meu deus do céu carnaval para se
divertir e que ela vai pra brincar
carnaval passei confusão gente carnaval
que tive aqui para brincar pra mim e pra
se divertir viu cantar a música agora
dói
eu olhe que eu quero subir olha aqui
entra na minha casa aqui na minha época
da campanha uma câmera de segurança da
onu olha tudo machê se tratar não essa
música da sua metralhadora vai ficar
você quando ela vira chiclete do mundo
inteiro o mundo ele quer fazer você ouve
de qualquer lado por seu todo ângulos aí
a música tá no avião atenção senhores
passageiros favor ao revelar seus cintos
pois estamos passando por uma área de
turbulência para o maior placar tratá lá
fora 9 mil de outro senhor vai ser o 20
campo e o dinheiro está nos pôr a cadeia
meu carro ficou maior e até trata meu
deus do céu de casa de meu deus quer ir
embora da roupa a igreja buscar jesus
mais escutar essas cotas na igreja lá o
pastor vai saindo saturnais vai sair do
tratato chega foi embora do brasil
levando o brasil a pessoa a pessoa ela
bota a música no carro de som
do outro lado da rua o terror por causa
de sua cama não basta escutar o caso da
menina tem que botar o dilema brigada
blade é tratada aqui travar é que matou
o primeiro eles você como é que foi o
carnaval aqui nos comentários se você
vai gostar desse vídeo já sabe fazer é
só clicar em gostei aqui no youtube bota
lá no facebook eu postei vídeo novo eu
sei que ela curte lá há postagens no
facebook marca seus amigos carnavalescos
lado comentário pra assistir esse vídeo
se inscreve no canal para nunca perder
um vídeo novo é nóis vai eu e valeu